In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for August 2, on which we commemorate, Blessed Basil,
full for Christ, and Wonderworker of Moscow.
Basil the Blessed, the most famous of the Holy Fools who flourished in Russia, was born
in the year 1464, in Elokov, a village near Moscow, of devout peasants, James and Anna.
Apprenticed to a shoemaker as a child, he lived an ascetic life, constantly at prayer,
and showing the first signs of divine grace.
At the age of sixteen, he was one day making fun of a merchant who had just ordered a great
many new boots.
When the client had gone, his master firmly asked him why he had behaved in that way.
The boy replied that it was strange to order boots in such numbers, to last many years
when the man was to die the next day.
His prophecy, having been fulfilled, Basil did not want to stay with his master, or return
to his parents, and he left for Moscow.
Lost in the noisy crowds of the city, he embraced the eschisies of fiend folly in order to participate
fully in the passion of our Lord Jesus Christ, while being shielded from the honor of men.
Having no fixed abode or even a hovel in which to lay his head, he lived almost naked in
the streets and public squares, spending his nights in prayer in church porches, and keeping
in the midst of the crowd a silence as profound as that of the desert fathers.
When he was obliged to speak, he pretended to speak with difficulty, a stranger to all men
having renounced the world and all its associations.
He showed, however, an immense compassion for the wretched, the sick, and the oppressed.
He also frequently visited the detainees in a prison for drunkards, exhorting them
to repent.
During a time when horror and oppression were holding sway, St. Basil's life was a living
condemnation of the corrupt boyars and a consolation to the people under trial.
And every action of his had a prophetic significance.
For instance, the blessed man often threw stones at the corners of the houses of the devout,
but when he passed the houses of those who lived in sin, he kissed the wall-angle.
When he was asked what he meant by this strange behavior, Basil replied that the houses
inhabited by holiness were no place for the demons, and he therefore, seeing them outside,
drove them away with stones.
On the other hand, in embracing the corners of houses where wickedness was practiced, he
was greeting the angels who were outside them, distraught at not being able to go in.
In the marketplace he destroyed the stalls of dishonest traders, and one day when the
czar had given him some money, as he often did, he did not give it away to the poor, but
to a well-dressed merchant, who, having lost his fortune, did not dare to beg and was suffering
from hunger.
In the year 1521, when the totters, led by Mechmet Idei, were threatening Moscow, St. Basil
prayed in front of the doors of the cathedral of the dormitian, beside the Kremlin, shedding
copious tears for the salvation of his homeland.
A fearsome noise was then heard in the church.
A flame sprang up, and a voice came from the icon of the Mother of God of Vladimir, stating
that she would forsake Moscow because of the sins of its inhabitants.
The saint intensified his prayer, and the terrible apparition ceased.
Mechmet Idei, who had already burned down the suburbs, was then turned back by the
appearance of a multitude of soldiers, and fled in haste across the borders of Russia.
czar Ivan the terrible loved the saint, and had a deep admiration for him, as did the holy
metropolitan Macarios.
On one occasion, being invited to the palace for the sovereign's birthday, the blessed
man, three times, poured wine out of the window, saying to the czar, who questioned him angrily,
that he was putting out a fire in Novgorod.
A little later, news was brought that a huge fire had in fact broken out in Novgorod, but
that it had been put out by a strange naked man who poured water on the burning houses.
The messengers, when they saw the man of God, realized that this had been basil.
On a further occasion, in the year 1547, the saint began to weep bitterly in front of the
church of the monastery of the exaltation of the cross.
On the exact spot, where a little later, the great fire that destroyed Moscow was to break
out.
Sometime after this sinister event, while the czar was present at the divine liturgy,
the blessed man was standing in a corner watching him.
After the liturgy, he said to the czar, you were not in church, but somewhere else.
The czar protested and basil replied, you are not speaking the truth.
I saw you going off in your thoughts, onto Sparrow Hill, to build a new palace there.
On that time, the czar began to be in awe of the saint and to show him even greater respect,
but this piety did not stop him practicing his legendary cruelty.
Saint Basil also appeared to the passengers on a Persian ship and saved them from shipwreck,
and he worked very many other miracles during the 72 years of his saving ministry.
Reaching the age of 88, he fell ill.
The emperor and his family, immediately being told of this, went to his bedside to ask
his prayers.
While Saint Basil was prophesying about the future of the kingdom, his face was radiant with
light as he contemplated an assembly of angels that had come to take his soul.
Caught up in ecstasy, he joyfully fell asleep on the 2nd of August in the year 1557.
The whole city was filled with fragrance and a huge crowd gathered for his funeral.
The emperor and his son carried him on their shoulders to the church where the metropolitan
and his bishops were waiting.
Upon his tomb, which became a source of healing for the faithful in their trials, not only
in Moscow, but in distant parts, a church was built dedicated to the protecting veil of
the mother of God in commemoration of the taking of Kazan, a church that was later called
after him.
The saint's miracles never ceased to multiply and his veneration was officially recognized
in the year 1558, in the time of Saint Job.
On that day, a hundred of the sick were healed in the presence of the saint's precious relics.
Saint Basil is venerated as the patron saint of the city of Moscow.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.